&gt;&gt; In one of our earlier quizzes when you were deciding which curves were
parabolas and which ones weren't, we saw the equation y equals 3x squared plus
2x. We know very well by now that if we want to find the x intercept of this
equation we need to start by setting y equal to 0, and then the next step after
that will be to try to get the expression on the right hand side, with the x's
in it, into a form where we have one factor multiplied by another factor. Where
both factors have an x to the 1st power in them. And in fact, you already know
how to do this. All this involves is factoring. Remember, that means looking for
a common factor between terms, and putting it outside a set of parenthesis so
that it will And multiply in. So, what is a way that we could rewrite this
equation by pulling out a common factor that both of these terms have. Please
fill in one of those factors here, and another one here.